a woman has gone viral for whining about
her job this clip thanks as always to
our friends over at Libs of Tik Tok
everybody is making fun of this woman
here's why I know I'm probably just
being so dramatic and annoying but this
is my first job like my first 9 to5 job
after college and I'm in person and I'm
commuting in the city and it takes me
forever to get there there's no way I'm
going to be able to afford living in the
city right now so that's off the table
like d if I was able to walk to work and
it it'd be fine but I'm not so it
literally takes me like I leave here
like I get on the train at 7:30 and I
don't get home till like 6:15 earliest
and then like I don't have time to do
anything I don't I want to shower eat my
dinner and go to sleep I don't have time
or energy to cook by dinner either like
I don't have energy to work out like
that's out the window like I'm so upset
oh my God nothing to do with my job at
all but just like the 9 to 5 schedule in
general is crazy being in the office 9
to 500 like if it was remote you get off
at 5:00 and you're home and everything's
fine but like I'm not home it takes me
long to get home and like like people
that drive to the office like it doesn't
you don't get off at 5: and I know it
could be worse I know I could be working
longer but like I literally get off it's
pitch black like I don't have energy how
do you have friends like how do you have
time to like meet like a guy I don't
know like how do you have time for like
dating like I don't have time for
anything and I'm like so stressed out
and I'm also getting my period so that's
why I'm all emotional but like am I so
dramatic it's
fine why are people making fun of her I
everything she said was right she opens
up she says hey I'm probably going to
sound really annoying and overly
dramatic here but anyway I'm going to
complain about my job because the cities
are too expensive to live in now and it
feels unnatural for me a lady to be
working in exactly the same way that a
man is which is true for most of human
history that would never have happened
but because of feminism we have to
pretend that men and women are exactly
the same she goes and I don't really
like that that doesn't make me feel good
or normal in any way and then I got to
commute all the way back and I do this
job I don't really like this job and I
I'm not getting paid enough so I can't
live closer so it makes it even harder
then I come back and I don't don't
really have much time for a a life and
it's very hard to date it is very hard
to date for young people especially in
this
stupid feminist society and it and Mal
ordered economy and then she says and by
the way you know I'm also just I'm I'm
about to menstrate so I'm probably just
being irrational which is also probably
true I I I give her not a 10 out of 10
but a nine out of 10 in the arguments
that she's
making the part that people are really
making fun of is that she's complaining
about working a 9 to5 because a lot of
people work a lot more than a 9 to5
though her argument is well it's more
than a 9o5 cuz I got to leave my house
an hour and a half before I actually get
there and I get back an hour hour and a
half later so it ends up being not an 8
hour job but more like a 10 or 11h hour
job and and that's true but even on that
point I think she's getting at something
really important right now go to Pur
talk.com P talk recently announced that
they would alleviate $10 million in
veteran debt by Veterans Day thanks to
your support last week Pure Talk is
53% toward that goal with two weeks to
go now just think about this we have a
100% volunteer military
men and women who raise their hands to
sacrifice for our country and when
they're done serving they come back to a
tight job market and an outrageous cost
of living expenses that is one of the
many reasons that I'm so happy a private
company like pure talk has jumped in to
help when you switch to P talks
Lightning Fast 5G Network they will
donate a portion of every new order to
this noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell service pure talks plans start at
just 20 bucks a month offering unlimited
talk text more data and mobile hotspot
just go to Pur talk.com kwes to make the
switch let's rally together and show our
unwavering support for our veterans go
to Pur talk.com switch to Pur talk today
it is the right move and it's the
American way it is important to do your
job with
purpose many people listening right now
do not work 9 to5 many people listening
right now maybe most don't work just 8
hours a day they work 9 or 10 or 11 or
12 I couldn't tell you the last time I
worked 8 hours a
day but then again I can't tell you the
last time I worked because my job
doesn't really feel like work but some
of the time it feels like work but a lot
of the time it doesn't because I'm doing
something that I feel is purposeful and
has meaning and I enjoy it or at the
very least even if I'm not actively
enjoying it at any given moment I'm
deriving some deal of satisfaction and
gratification from it and and this can
be true of any job you can consecrate
any kind of work even the sort of work
that Elites would sneer at and say is
meaningless or drudge work or menial uh
no you can consecrate that work to God
you can you can find profound meaning in
that I mean a classic example of this is
if all of the journalists suddenly
disappeared from the earth tomorrow
nothing would change if all of the
plumbers or sanitation workers
disappeared from the Earth society would
come to a grinding halt within about 12
hours there's deep meaning in that even
though in our society we we deny such a
thing and we pretend that the only work
that matters is I don't know Hollywood
or journalists or some wacko academics
in their Ivory
Towers but no there there there has to
be meaning there but so the the issue
that she's complaining about is not just
uh my job is annoying sometimes which is
an issue that every single person who
has ever lived will deal with the issue
that she's she's complaining about is
the dir of meaning which ties right back
in with with what we're talking about
when it comes to speaker
Johnson if you think that there's no
point to life that we're just here to
feel pleasure at any given moment you're
going to be miserable most of the time
because you got to work you got to work
at your job you got to work on your
personal relationships you got to work
in your home you got to you got to work
by the sweat of our brow we will we will
have our food
if you think there is a a purpose though
which is okay I'm not just going to date
aimlessly I'm going to get married and
I'm not just going to be in a
partnership like the Liberals talk about
today but I'm going to have a real
family and I'm going to have kids if I'm
blessed to have kids and I'm going to
raise those kids and I'm going to do so
for a purpose because I think that we're
here to uh be fruitful and multiply and
to flourish in our communities and to
pursue the good and to glorify God
you're going to have a much easier time
and that 8- hour job is going to feel a
lot shorter and that 12-hour job is
going to feel like an 8 hour job and
you're not going to be concerned about
uh all the time you feel you're wasting
in fact you're going to feel like there
isn't enough time at all man that was a
great clip huh wasn't it I agree make
sure that you ring the bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see
you next time